it's like pinch me it's a dream still
like like nine months ago nobody knew
who I was people thought I was just like
this tall skinny white kid who couldn't
really who just there could a pause s
seven feet tall
even if people don't know you they
always stop you and they're like how
tall are you you play basketball but
people ask me for signatures don't even
know who I am like just you're gonna be
in the NBA one day just cuz I'm taller
like I've always been like 99th
percentile of my height but 8th grade I
grew 7 inches started at like 62 ended
at 69 so yeah that was a rough year step
in step in step in so when I go you can
get it first made sure in third grade
when he walked into practice with his
long khaki shorts
Skylar T Shore and his little busted
kicks I showed up to the first practice
in cargo shorts and I had a bulk I was
not ready for for AAU basketball yeah
and I was having a basketball tournament
he's probably bought big as a pencil at
that time but really long and and frail
and really weak I think I cried after
the first week of practice every
practice but I just couldn't handle it
he looked like a big thing extreme
teased you know just looking goofy out
there and I kind of took him under my
wing I like my little brother and now
he's like my little big brother cuz he's
seven feet hey this is o'clock it's just
score awareness that'd be a good shot
any time it's not one point away from
getting just beat down by jailing them
over and over again you know you become
a product your environment and one thing
men Larry sucks are big on in our
program it's toughness what he's doing
right now it's not a surprise is his
validation of what means myself and the
body of work that Larry Suggs is put in
with him and he you know Jets carried
out it everything we can do Ansem as a
youngster he was coach
to be a shooter in a lot of guard skills
so they didn't just stick him in the
post they taught him multiple skills and
for him that transcended really well I
don't know how many schools out there
that never get the opportunity to have a
7-footer who could handle the ball who
shoots who has a great attitude who
works hard who you don't have to worry
about in the classroom you know he's
very unique
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this was like a meteoric rise for him
when we won our third state championship
in a row that obviously helps but he
really helped himself this year on the
AAU circuit as well I'd say Steph Curry
was a turning point of everybody knowing
about the stuff he did the Steph Curry
we've seen him do it before but it was
Steph Curry everybody's matched up and
I'm looking around like where's the last
person like and then I see Steph I'm
like oh hi I'll go guard I'm like never
scared never back down Steph Curry
wonderful friends were all chat beated
against the glass said get that out of
here
Steph Curry you know start here he
started laughing I think I booked him
one time on a backdoor layup and then
like I knew I was gonna hit him with the
dragon and out I knew I was gonna do
something I knew he was coming down to
make a move because you know he does
look where he stops and hesitates and he
starts to slow down and he went behind
the back boom and then he bit went on
the first behind the back so I just
double wrapped it and then he kind of
hopped that way so I got around instead
I've kind of jumped it and when I seen
him do the cycling I was out and you
know coming down middle lane I know he's
gonna donkey he's gotta end it up right
stuff he was like got me on that one the
next time down if you look at the plate
first plate he break your check comes
out on him
step-back three looks right a check on
number one he hit me with but he didn't
there was something that was kind of
vicious pulled up from like 28 feet or
something
kudos to curry because he I guess he
handled it really well in fact it was
complementing a chat you know on that
move and and and I don't know if you've
seen the side by side of that move it's
incredible how close it
that's digit to Curry's moving he's
really cool he's like it's just one play
doesn't really matter and like I have
the same mindset cuz as somebody who
jumps with everybody and everything like
I've gotten dumped on my fair share of
times and like it's a mindset you just
can't worry about it next play basically
last year this time I was at one point
2k Instagram followers and now I'm at
seventy two point four thanks
it's like pinch me to dream still like
like nine months ago nobody knew who I
was because I thought I was just like
this tall skinny white kid who couldn't
really who's just there cuz he's tall
but now like people know who I am
people know what I can do like I try not
to pay too much attention to it just
kind of focus on myself and just kind of
staying humble cuz like there's also
been a lot of praise and good words said
about me I've told commit several
college kill just way before he started
playing this coming year I'll tell you
right now holmgren he's gonna be the
best player in that class I told him
time and time again
I mean he's excited nearly every major
college in the country right now
this is not this is not any type of list
this is not any type of talk anything
this is just schools that have reached
out to me
Kansas UNC Kentucky Duke Minnesota
Gonzaga Iowa Iowa State Marquette Purdue
Michigan Michigan State Georgetown
Maryland Texas Texas A&M Louisville's
reached out people are calling him all
the time now so we actually had to tell
him you know what Jeff you got to put
your phone away you got to go to sleep
at night just like I said he wants to he
wants to please everybody and he's so
engaging that he'll stay on the phone
and talk with coaches for hours my goal
is for my career get buckets and win
basketball obviously I want to be a
professional basketball player I want to
win at every level I've already won
three state championships going into my
junior year now so hopefully I can get a
couple more before my time is up and
then I want to win one in college and
then I want to win however many I can in
the pros if I can make it there I mean
that's that's kind of my dream that's
been my dream
I just check Holmgren on be our hoops
congrats on a million followers we're
out